now i'm gonna say something that is very
controversial and i
keep saying i am not proud of being
greek
you cannot be proud of being puerto
rican you cannot be proud of being
african
you cannot be proud of being bangladesh
or whatever else you're
[Music]
a lot of people have this misconception
that uh you know once i feel closer to
god then i'm gonna start practicing
it's backwards you won't feel close to
god until you start practicing the
prophet i said
there's a hadith where he says that the
most beloved acts of worship to god are
those which he made obligatory the
person continues to get closer and
closer to allah
key point gets closer and closer by
voluntary acts of good
so like sudden things you know for the
sake of allah things that are not
obligatory but you do them just to
please allah
until allah begins to love the person so
two things you want to feel close to
allah you want allah to love you
do what allah prescribes for you which
is
so praying fasting
and then on top of that sunnah prayers
suddenly fasts
giving extra charity to the point where
allah will inshallah begin to love you
brothers and sisters all over the world
and welcome to the realest
i podcast podcast actually in the world
the best one in the in
north america but actually one of the
best in the world is not even the best
one
with your host doctor steph curry's and
who's the rest angel rami and fayette
mashallah
all of us here all together all four of
us i think are we the
the most handsomest guy in the world who
are we what are we actually exactly
how shall we how shall we introduce
ourselves
today is a very special episode by the
way i would like to take you a little
bit to north america
to the caribbean to south america to the
connection between
africa europe and the americans
especially the islamic history of all
these continents and
anybody might say now whoa whoa what's
happening america
you know north america caribbean south
america islam
where does this come from are you
talking about migrants talking about
some arab migrants or asian migrants
coming to america
no that's not what i'm talking about not
at all
africa many people might think like come
on what's happening i'm in africa yes
there are some muslims there we know
that
but how deep does it go now if i told
you now
islam in africa was
present first in africa before it was
even present in uh
in arabia what i mean with that it
became
an important part a mark
of african society before it even became
a mark in arabia
it does not of course mean our prophet
muhammad came of course from mecca we
all know that
he was on the arabian peninsula he was
an arab himself
he of course gathered a lot of arabs
around him
but who was the first ruler to accept
islam was he an arab
no who was the first um
um important person ruling a country of
being in another continent even
it was an african then najashi the
ruler of that time abyssini as it was
called by the arabs
abyssinia was al aqsum that was
basically an empire
which was in east africa in the horn of
africa which nowadays
and it's in three it's divided amongst
three four countries ethiopia eritrea
somalia north somalia djibouti all these
countries are part of the horn of africa
and aksum or basically abyssinia havasha
at that time
was an empire which even
even had colonized the yemen so
the southern part of arabia so
i think angel is looking at the map
would you ever map that
okay can you see it you have a map there
no it's finally we need we need a map
guys we need a map we need something
like that you know
so anyway maybe with anything you could
put a map in of haunt the horn of africa
so aksum the empire in east africa and
the horn of africa
and being the first empire having the
first
emperor who accepted and embraced the
faith allah
and this is extremely important and we
forget it or we don't even
acknowledge that the very first ruler in
the world was not an
arab was not um european but it was in
africa
okay next to this one with that
with that with islam becoming an an
integral part of africa of east africa
and the horn of africa
it becomes of course an important
integral part of the whole of africa of
the continent of africa
and it settled indeed the muslims
settled for a longer period of time
in eastern africa before they could go
back again
and made the hijra to medina okay
and from there basically the islamic
state developed in medina but actually
long before the islamic state of medina
they had already built
mosques massage it in east africa and
the oldest one
in the world can actually be found in
nowadays eritrea somalia
okay two of them there is even one which
is basically
meaning two qiblas the old one towards
jerusalem
and the other one of course towards kipp
mecca as we all know we are over a
situation that
rasulullah was told in a specific time
to turn from jerusalem towards mecca
right
when allah tells us basically told the
muslim ummah to turn towards mecca
and we have this masjid which is called
masjidaki platine
meaning two qiblas but not only in
arabia there's another one
in uh nowadays editorial the corn of
africa
these are amazing facts i find and it
extremely interesting i think
if somebody can travel after corona of
course
whoever is the chance to travel please
take your family and go and see this
extremely interesting
part of the world and especially what is
known as ethiopia
triagi beauty somalia very interesting
uh
countries um i must have haven't the
chance yet i actually
have traveled through books to that part
of the world i didn't have the chance
simply because of the war situation in
somalia
uh because of instability in certain
parts
ethiopia is all right and it has a bit
more difficult
djibouti seems to be okay again but um
um these this these mosques we're
talking about are mainly in eritrea and
somalia
where there's a lot happening at the
moment has been happening a lot for the
last couple of
years um so yes i'm taking you basically
to to to see to experience africa in a
totally different way
and i found personally i love africa i
love the continent of africa
um and i personally have traveled
several times to africa to several
places of africa
to southern africa i've been to west
africa north africa
and it is fascinating to see um how
islam
has indeed any part of africa and
you might say now some of you might
think okay but southern africa did not
have a lot of influence from the muslims
the muslims never went to southern
africa
that is not really entirely correct what
is interesting is to see
that islam in southern africa did not go
the way it went to west africa north
africa east africa
through arabs and muslims who accepted
islam
but in southern africa listen carefully
it went
because of our european colonialists the
dutch
who actually occupied indonesia and you
know indonesia is the biggest
muslim the largest muslim majority
country in the world
more than 200 million muslims now that
time it used to be
a dutch colony and the dutch
they decided to colonize his people as
europeans did normally you know they
used to do these things
they used to go to other people's places
think that they are at home and make it
their home
so they did the same in in indonesia and
who
had a problem with that of course the
muslims living there
the ulama actually declared jihad
against the dutch
so the dutch thought hey guys no no no
you know what we're gonna do
we're gonna take these scholars because
they clear trouble
and we sent them to the deepest africa
so we sent them to our other colony in
the cape down in south africa
so they sent scholars who created
trouble for them
down to the southern part of africa and
what happens there
allah plans better right these these
ulama these scholars were put in houses
on their own somewhere in the desert to
die
black people african people who are
living of course in that part of the
world
used to flee away from their european
colonizers
and would find refuge in these houses
and they would listen
to what the sheikhs had to say and that
these scholars
actually taught them quran there are
even quran
originally from that time written by
hand by the scholars
and black people would accept islam on
mass
so islam spread to throughout the
southern part of africa
okay now mind-blowing isn't it
so now we should thank the colonialists
for that we should thank
the the dutch people you know i was i
was living in holland by the way five
years in amsterdam
and um it's very interesting to to see
how they
perceive this type of history which they
don't know because when they hear it
from somebody else
it's always insulting to them like for
example the swiss people when they hear
actually that
muslims were in switzerland long before
there was an existing switzerland as we
know it as a country
so they feel insulted that a muslim
comes and tells them
these things but historical facts are
there
anybody can look them up anybody will
find that and
it is interesting to see that nowadays
of the strongest
western muslim community in the world we
can find them in southern africa
in parts such as in south africa
especially in the country of south
africa but also in botswana
in zimbabwe and in namibia you can find
muslim communities throughout these
countries
very interesting to see so we started
with something mind-blowing actually i
didn't want to go too deep into it but i
just wanted to show you a connection
the whole world is connected brothers
especially islamically
asia is connected with africa africa is
connected connected with europe
europe is connected with the americas
america is connected with africa and
that's where we go back to australia
again
okay so amazing amazing and if you look
at this
at the world like this you know if you
just have
the world maybe in front of you and i
used to as a child i used to
i used to just sit and observe the world
map just have it in front of me
and just try to find the country and
capitals of countries
and i was always planning when i would
go where
um when i'm 18 19 i was saying when i
have my high school degree
first thing i'm going to do is travel
the world and i was traveling the world
already since i was like 14 15 on the
map on the world map
and i had learned actually i can see it
in front of me now i can see the world
in front of me i can see the continents
i can see actually cities i can see the
capitals
and i find it amazing amazing okay
and um i i really i cannot imagine
anything better than that traveling the
world
and getting to know other people other
cultures as well
and it is of course more interesting
being muslim that time i was not even
muslim
now being a muslim trying to discover
going to a masjid somewhere in south
africa
or going to hamashia somewhere in
botswana you know you don't know anybody
here just going to the masjid they all
pray the same way we're all there we're
all muslims
you always come across people it's
amazing it is
amazing so i don't know if i said too
much already but
please i give you the word now
subhanallah it's completely mind-blowing
subhanallah um
like a part of me knew that but i never
internalized that about najashi
um but first i have a question is is
najashi a name or is it a title
it's a title you know it's something
like the emperor okay okay
because um i remember hearing once that
najashi accepted islam
and then after that there is some talks
about islam with the najashi and this
not the other
but he was a christian or something like
that and uh then the
the imam said that najashi is just a
title because people get confused with
that someone i wouldn't be sure about
subhan allah so the dutch sent
scholars from indonesia to south africa
and because of that
um africans native africans started
accepting islam and that's how islam
really started to uh to build itself
there to grow in south africa
yeah absolutely correct um and the it
has become indeed i was in south africa
i
had the chance to make a small tour
actually through south africa
um some years back and it was very
interesting to see
um that people uh the muslim community
is very much aware of these people of
that time
it's not hidden history it's for us
hidden history for them down there not
at all especially in cape town
and on robben island as you know nelson
mandela was there it was a prison island
and on that very prison island many
muslims were also imprisoned there by
the way
and because of being political prisoners
of course so
on that island you can still find graves
from that time
of scholars of in from of indonesian
background
who were buried there so there are
islamic cemeteries there
um and there's an old quran which i saw
myself martial are beautiful to see
which was hand written by one of the
scholars and i think in the whole of
south africa
there are three in the cape that our
original handwritten quran
museums amazing absolutely amazing to
see
so there you see again when somebody
says why do i need to know the quran by
heart nowadays
we have all this digital stuff we have
the quran
on on on youtube whatever i can
it's no problem once we might not have
it
one something might happen because that
time i'm very sure nobody had thought in
indonesia
come on why do i need to know the quran
why do i need to know it if i have it
everything i have it here i have so many
scholars who can teach me
i'm sure that many people thought the
same that time but there you go
if they hadn't known the quran by that
time they wouldn't have been able to
transfer it to give it through to the
people who needed it that time masha
allah
and um yeah that you know you see again
how we
we draw conclusions out of what's
happening in history guys
we have to understand that's what i keep
telling my my students every time
we not we are not learning history
because of certain dates of battle or
battles that happen
okay they might not even be of
importance it doesn't really matter what
kind of battle happened in 1492 or
7-eleven
but what does matter is why the arrival
of clarification
in in gibraltar was so important and
what the result is of that
okay so the battle in itself is not
important but the result of it is
okay now a date yes it is good to have a
general idea i mean that you know that
the middle ages is that time that time
that around a certain time something
happened but we are getting the school
system
has become a system
that teaches you really just some dates
and battles that you have to learn by
heart with regards to history
you sit in front of an exam you just you
know
pick the right battle the right date or
whatever it is
and you think you have learned history
okay
now that's not what history is about
history is first of all identity
second of all is what we learn from okay
the result
of history what is history about what
has what has it taught actually really
in the past and what do we take with us
nowadays from the past uh to the present
and this
if we take it from the past to the
present that we learn
that will teach us actually we will
learn how to um
move further into the future because how
do you build a future if you don't know
your past
and that's exactly what happened in the
americas for example with all
these people being taken from africa um
exported you know just being taken
actually
kidnapped take them into the americas
not allowing them to even find out who
the ancestors actually are
many of them still don't know that and
they're lost
lost you become a lost person you're
lost
next to this one you didn't have the
chance to develop um
a bond with a family um
it's not a miracle that you will find
among certain communities
problems with regards to marital life
they don't they cannot have a marital
life because they don't know how to do
that
they just don't know how to how to be
good fathers and they don't know
how to be good husbands and they don't
know how to be good wives
okay this all goes back to that time
this is all history
this is all history okay if we try to
explain to somebody what islam is about
we also go back to explain the seed of
rasulullah that's history
you know our life is full of history
without realizing
without realizing it and it is sad to
see
how many of the students sorry i can
give you the word each other very soon
but it's very very sad to see how many
of my students under the students
in general do not realize the importance
of your past
and your past is your history it's your
identity it's who you are
i can please i'm saying that's crazy
because uh
african-americans they really don't know
where they come from and they might want
to say
like oh well i can just track my last
name it's like sorry buddy but your last
name was probably given to you
by uh you know a caucasian person at
some point or another down the line like
you probably got this last name that's
not it's not part of your family it's
really not part of you
and like you probably will never know
that cause like in africa they don't
have
last names like smith
johnson jackson yeah yeah
absolutely right yes i think that's
crazy yeah like
absolutely for myself you know for
myself being puerto rican
uh if i go to puerto rico like i have a
specific community
where like it's called um
which is like literally like everyone in
that community is
my last name like part of my family and
it goes way way back and um
even then me having that i still don't
know where i fully come from because
like there's a cut off
and once that cut off hits like you
don't know what happened before that
yes yes yes yes do it definitely you
were deprived of that absolutely exactly
because the only thing you know
basically is
that you you do have some hispanic
background obviously you do have some
some spanish roots but your actual roots
are for sure the continent of africa and
where exactly again you don't know you
can just assume
most probably west africa but again it
doesn't have to be west africa
it can be anywhere because prisoners of
wars were taken from a lot of places
allah subhanallah it's really
unbelievable but i think
isn't it like this that with accepting
islam with
embracing islam it has given you an
identity a real identity
because despite the fact that we might
know i know my
i can go far back i'm relapped to a
certain i can go far back
but still if you ask me nowadays
and if i talk about my ancestors i
actually refer rather to my
muslim ancestors and to my greek
ancestors um
i don't feel so connected to my
ancient greek roots as i feel to um
for example
these are people who i look up to i
don't look up to
ulysses and to this kind of people who
are supposed to
have lived if at all um
of course i'm not denying this for the
greek
viewers here who are going to write some
comments you cannot imagine they're
going to be
you know some crazy comments down here
but i'm not saying that it's not
important to know
uh about our answers greek ancient greek
ancestors and philosophers and whatever
they did sophocles platinum
aristotle and all these people amazing
of course
but there is no divinity there okay
now they have come up with ideas which
is great fantastic but again they made
mistakes
and they made many mistakes simply
because they had no divine
guidance they did not have the quran
they did not have allah's rule
and they did not have allah's words and
this is more important
than having some kind of philosophical
ideas which might be true it might not
be
so you know
just trying to yeah
because you keep hearing that you know
you keep hearing that yeah you should be
proud of being greek
you should be proud of your ancestors
you should be proud of your history
how can you be proud of being greek
without having done anything for it
now again you know look at the comments
now that will come
now i'm gonna say something that is very
controversial and i
keep saying it i am not proud of being
greek
you cannot be proud of being puerto
rican you cannot be proud of being
african you cannot be proud of being
bangladesh or whatever else you are
why you did not choose it brothers
did any one of you choose to be what you
are did we choose to have the color we
have did we choose to have the eye color
we have did we choose to have
um the way we look did we choose
no did you choose your mother no we
didn't none of us
so how can i be proud of something i
didn't do anything for
but you know what i'm proud of being
muslim because i chose for being
i chose for islam i chose for it
alhamdulillah and i'm proud of being
muslim
i'm proud of having reached my academic
degrees i'm proud of being an academic
yes i'm proud of that because i've done
something for it i've worked for it
okay and god knows i've worked my battle
for that i tell you that
it was not easy in germany it was not
easy as a foreigner growing up in
germany
to reach the stage where i've reached so
i'm proud of that
i'm proud of speaking several languages
yes
i'm proud of them but i cannot be proud
of my color
i cannot be proud of being greek and i
cannot be proud of having a certain
nationality
as none of you can i didn't do anything
for that
that's true you know again what i'm
saying is controversial many people say
but brother how can you say that how can
you say you're not proud of being greed
now explanation what i mean i'm not
ashamed of being
but i did not do anything for it so yes
i am i am looking and i have looked of
course into my ancestry
and i have looked into what it actually
means ancient greece civilization
fantastic amazing stuff yes and i find
it interesting and i like it
nice but i'm not proud of it because
again
these are the people who did that that
time and that's these people who did
that
neither my uncle nor my parents nor
myself
okay so it might at first moment when
you hear it it might sound quite
controversial and like what is this guy
saying
and i've had this conversation actually
i would say nearly every lecture
every lecture at the end i have this
kind of conversation especially when
you're in germany
and you have a lot of a big turkish
community and the turks have learned one
thing
the turks especially in turkey have
learned to be proud of being turks
not of being muslim okay and
then they see a greek muslim you know
who is supposed to be their arch enemy
standing there in front of them and tell
them you cannot be proud of being
turkish
i'm not proud of being green the whole
idea of the world the concept of the
world has broken down suddenly
they're like they don't know what to say
and what to do because all their lives
that have
they have been taught that they have to
be proud of being turkish
as many other people by the way not the
church but the turks are a good example
okay because they have exchanged in
turkey turkey is a secular country the
only muslim secular country in the world
okay the only secular country which has
the majority of population being muslims
and they are officially secular which
means they're trying to divide whatever
they're trying to do
they're trying to keep religion out of
public affairs
which is islam is in islam impossible
but they they say they do that they say
they're secular
so but you have a lot of turkish people
in between who are very nice people
masha
excellent people i love turkey but what
i don't love is the ideology which has
exchanged islam
okay and this has gone back the last 50
to 20 years things have become much
better in turkey
and the turks have realized also the
islamic roots and elements very
important
they have changed a lot hamdarillah
actually most of the turks nowadays have
grown up with this ideology of
nationalism
as most of us have and the idea that
um a certain people or nation is better
than
other people or nations okay
and this is a cancer in the entire world
and definitely the muslim
subhanallah
i'm not asking for the sake of being
proud um but we talk about how important
it is to know your roots and history
uh so i'm a bit curious because i'm
palestinian alhamdulillah but i don't
know um where i come from other than
that i don't know the history
behind you know how my ancestors got to
palestine where they came from
and i think my mom uh actually said we
may be uh we may be
like our ancestors may be greek or um
this not the other sub allah
but other than you know i don't really
know
where they come from so uh how would i
go about finding that out i think we
talked a bit about that in episode one
but um indeed uh we did uh speak uh
mention this a bit
um yeah look in your case of course it's
very interesting to find out
about the middle east actually the whole
situation of palestine there was a
church you know what what was happening
what happened in the last 50 60 years
which has changed the whole region
entirely but
you might even go much much further i
mean we're talking about ancient times
where you have
high civilizations that have developed
in that area you have babylonians
assyrians
all these people in the middle east that
develop high civilization psychologists
and it is quite interesting what i would
do in your case because there's a lot to
actually discover um i would take um
they do have them actually they're not
even that expensive nowadays they're
these
world history kind of books no but they
go back to
they give you a general idea they have
them in in phases so they give you an
idea of the
world history and that in phases so
sometimes
within um maybe some pages
topic number one number two number three
like this that gives you a very general
idea
not too complicated not too much and
still good enough to get get you an idea
and then i would go deeper into
something that you're more interested in
if you say
you read something about let's say the
babylonians okay
who were in that area um and you want to
know something within a certain time
period and a certain time period you can
go online nowadays mashallah just google
the time period or just google the
babylonians you know
and then like this the one brings the
other so that's what i would do in your
case actually all of you inshallah the
same thing
um the same [ __ ] i mean if you want to
know something about the indian
subcontinent i mean mashallah
again a massive big part of history
you can go back to the time of the
hindus and the sikhs
finding out that actually your people
originally were english
you know no you know what that's
fascinating because i grew up i'm 23 now
or i'm turning to 23 soon
i grew up most of my life knowing that
you know we've always been muslim
and just a couple weeks ago my dad was
like
i think no i don't think it was four or
six but something like that generations
ago we weren't even muslim
of course and we were here for hindus
most of the people on the indian
subcontinent were hindus
before there were even more mushrikeen
there's even more than that so
from muslim to mishra even worse so
there's there's there
but but fascinating culture fascinating
don't forget one thing yes they commit
their shirk
from the theological perspective
islamically seen
however however the zero the idea of
mathematics and many things came from
there
and the arab muslims from that time
didn't have a problem with taking from
indians
and from chinese by the way like the
compass for example
um taking it over from that part of the
world to bring it to europe
okay so there's nothing wrong with that
there is nothing wrong with that there's
still a lot that can be learned from
their civilization their culture
but not theologically of course we don't
deal with with
with the theological aspect with the
religious aspect but you can take
a lot of other things which our
ancestors actually showed before that
they did
and we can still do that mashallah as
long as it's within the framework of
islam
and the framework of islam is as much as
you know your knowledge goes
and that's all we need to learn a lot
about what's gonna ask do you know
much about the roots of like hinduism
like did they get
divine revelation or was it kind of like
not
that it's yeah masha it's
it's a very good question indeed look
allah tells us basically we know that
more than 20 000 prophets have been sent
out
all over the world and any people on
this planet
have had a profit any people on this
planet that means also
the ancient greeks must have also had a
profit and if i look at some
um um some authentic
sources that go back to certain ancient
greek philosophers
um it sounds to me like some of them
um and i'm not very sure if it was
aristotle or platon they are talking
about
the divinity of one god and we're
talking about ancient greece socrates
yeah i'm not very sure now exactly but
they're talking about
one god and it's not just one by the way
there were more
who actually followed the idea that
there's one god and not twelve
as they used to believe so buddha
if you look at buddha you're not looking
at the buddhists nowadays and the
statues
if you look at the life of buddha allahu
akbar for me
the little things that i know about
buddha i think
uh i could imagine the buddha was
actually sent as a prophet to his people
i could imagine a buddha might have been
a prophet might have been a prophet
okay any people have seen a prophet any
people have had a prophet
that's what allah tells us so that means
prophets have been sent all over the
world to any kind of people to any kind
of language
so most probably amongst these people
who are worshipped nowadays who have
made statues and whatever
many of them amongst them most probably
were righteous people and most probably
they were even prophets
subhanallah so okay
so like way back original hindu
scriptures
could have been sent from divine
revelation
if you look at um it would be
of interest for you to take a look at um
old tapes you know
if you look at his old tapes seeing that
he has
a very good knowledge of that part of
the world i remember that he even
once had a debate with regards to the um
hindu scriptures in islam and he had
some excellent things that i didn't
believe my ears actually when i heard
that actually
he came up with hindu scriptures
describing one god
[Music]
i was going to say that it's sorry
we speak too much i speak too much okay
come on say it what do you want to say
yeah no so first thing what you were
saying about the uh
uh the greek and how you had certain
people saying uh oh there's actually
only one god
uh well you can't have the the belief
in multiple gods without the belief in
one god like the idea of multiple gods
comes from the idea of one god you know
and aside from that like
the hindus i've spoken to romney and
fight about this where it's like i feel
that um you know allah has been trying
to guide all of us
all humanity throughout history and it's
like
we all have or like everywhere that you
look there's pieces of the puzzle but
then when you look at islam
you have the complete puzzle it's all
there it's all there and it says it's
clearly in the quran where it's like
today i have completed my favor my
blessing affected you
i've perfected your religion and it's
like dude if you look at the hindus
they actually like you said in the vedas
the ancient hindu scriptures
they speak that there is only one god
and the supposedly like i have a
this old friend he's hindu but he's like
he's like a legit hindu and he tells me
everything he's like
you look like there is only one god like
all the hindus
or like nine out of ten hindus are
getting it wrong because uh
what you see is the idols you got
intermediary
krishna and um ganesh and all this stuff
but it's like
all these people were this translation
of
god they were it's a it's a terrible
translation and what they actually are
it's this word in
in a hindi that i i forget it right now
but i think it's called um
bhagava bhagavatam like that and what it
basically means is just an
enlightened one one who is just at a
higher level like of understanding
not that they're a god that they just
understand more but the problem is is
when people start to
put them as these idols that's when
people bro
we we don't know any better so if you
don't have a clear-cut way
a template of hey this is what we're
supposed to do
then you just have all these things
around you you kind of get confused
you're like ah okay well
i guess this is this is a god and i
guess this is a god over here
and then you start worshiping these
idols instead of
instead of the the main thing the main
message which was that there was one god
and it's crazy that it's it's in the
ancient
hindu vedas the ancient hindu scriptures
absolutely yes absolutely it is um
extremely important uh to look into what
just said because indeed it has been
mentioned
it has been mentioned uh previously and
i i don't know of anybody else but
already that i know that he mentioned
these things
very explicitly and i know that he has
had many debates with regards to that
but because obviously in europe you're
not that interested in in
the hindu scriptures in india we are
more interested
in the bible of course and everything
that affects us directly even
uh jewish life rather than hindu life we
don't have that much in europe
but um in your case especially if i yet
you might be interested in finding out
about that
and i really think it is extremely
important because i think you will come
to the same conclusion that all of us
here
have come to you know that actually our
ancestors
might have been mushrik but actually
they went
they got it wrong okay so actually there
was one god
that their beliefs actually they believe
actually was telling them to believe in
one god
you know the same as we just said mayan
says let's say if you take the ancient
greeks the same thing if you took now
all
ancient cultures in the area of the
middle east you will also see that
actually they got it wrong they just
created statues as anchor said
there was just the idea of people people
wanted to they have the need
to worship so they need to worship if
you don't have the path and the right
way to worship
you just create something so you make
out of tree you make a god
the tree becomes your god okay and if
it's not the tree
it's gonna be um a statue that you
create
if it's not the statue it's gonna be
money and then you call yourself an
atheist
damn or like a cow so they don't eat
like beef whatever
yes okay subhanallah you know
so it is extremely interesting to see
and indeed
islam that's what i've realized myself
you look into all these cultures into
different places the different religions
the different peoples
you look into their way of worshiping
you look into their history
and basically islam brings them all
together it's like that's it
that is it that's what you all guys are
looking for
that is exactly the point where you have
to all gets them
okay it's like they're all halfway there
but they have never reached the stadium
unless they have accepted the deed so
amazing absolutely amazing the way it
was like
so let me say this once because that is
that is something i
this conversation i've had with my wife
at the very beginning i remember because
she herself was not a muslim by the way
at the beginning when we met
i was a muslim and um i had to
i had to explain to her uh that i cannot
just date
yeah you know i told you right so i had
to explain this to her
but it was it was interesting it was
interesting to see actually that she
just grabbed it and she was like yeah
i understand it so the same conversation
with at that time actually if
if you look at anybody's ancestors
anybody's answers on this planet
they all were mushrik ones okay they
were all actually believing in
the trees the plants nature gods statues
all of them once was there but before
them
before that time there was also a time
that actually there was a belief in one
god
and again what you said before actually
if you believe in more gods
the logical thing is that all these gods
come under one umbrella there must be a
one one god above them
because how do they you know so and in a
way the ancient greeks
actually also believed in zeus being the
main god name
what zeus was the god and all the others
were under him
so there we go again there was actually
one god and all the others
being under him so following god's
another yeah
yes yes yes the romans had the same
thing
yeah there was a of the greek
absolutely the romans come on now let's
be honest you know because i'm greek but
they're almost just copy the greeks
okay and the the truth is what they did
they just took the 12 gods of the greeks
gave them a latin name and there we go
have exactly the same gods basically
creating and building the same temples
like in greece if you go to rome
which i must be honest come on honestly
athens is a much nicer place
so if you compare athens to rome
honestly
rome is a a city of megalomaniacs
okay it's like you see these massive
temples
um a cheap copy of the real of of the
real acropolis in athens for example of
the real temples
in athens you see these copies and
you're thinking like these guys actually
just wanted to be better than the greeks
but they have never reached them
they could never reach a stadium and the
other thing is next to this one you know
let's compare the italians to the greeks
i have to always laugh when i
when i when i look at the the countries
that the italians colonized
i don't know how they did it high
italians but colonized people
but they somehow did it um but most
probably they went in there and they
fell in love with all the women there
okay and they colonize the country right
some are like this
that's how conventional colonization
otherwise i cannot imagine how italians
colonize the country
you know i mean there are more lovers
than fighters you know i don't
understand how italians
could colonize so so if you go back to
the romans
the romans were just you know they just
copied ancient greece
ancient greek philosophy and ancient
greek
belief and everything it all just is the
copy
just basically put into latin that's it
so yeah i had to say that i have a lot
of italian friends i always talk around
with them okay
always guys always we joke around so
don't worry it's not racism okay
uh yeah i forgot i forgot what i was
gonna say
something about the romans you wanted to
say something about the wrong uh
i think it was before the romans
all right i don't know anymore i don't
know
okay little silence a little silence um
but yeah okay so to
to carry on to carry on if if we look at
uh different cultural practices because
you know you have the
greeks you have the romans and they have
all these different gods
i mean if you look at uh
the polynesians if you look at the
um i can't speak 100
on the the mayans and stuff like that
but
they had multiple gods and i know that
there was always
that idea where it's like okay well we
can't just have
the god for this god for this god for
this god for this and they're all equal
like we have to have one god that's like
superior above all these other gods
and that's where you have that one god
but it's just
again like you can't have you can't have
the um and i heard this
directly from ferraza hobby so i might
butcher this
he said it perfectly in one of his
videos i mean i know you know what i'm
talking about fayad as well
but um he says you can't have the idea
of multiple guys without the idea of one
guy
where it's like if i tell you right now
uh think about a mountain you can think
about a mine because
you've probably seen the mine maybe a
picture maybe in person or something
like that
and if i tell you oh think about gold
you you can
you your mind can create that gold image
because you'll be the single you felt it
or something along the lines but if i
tell you have you ever seen
a gold mountain can you imagine a gold
mine you're like oh well i've never seen
a gold mountain
um and it's very hard for me to imagine
a gourmand but i
can kind of do it if i try to bring
these two
ideas uh the mountain and the gold but
it's like the gold mountain couldn't
have come without
mountain and gold you see what i'm
saying where it's like
the god of war couldn't have come
without
war and god
so essentially it all comes back to just
one god
yes it's exactly the same idea you know
um
what we said about the greeks basically
um they might have had 12
main gods but there was one main god you
know there was zeus
and he was the main guy he was the boss
of all of them let's call it that way
and anybody had to everybody to listen
to him
you know and then you had semi gods who
actually came out of his relationship
with um um women with human beings
right and then there were semi gods
right so
hercules for example was a semi god
right and that was nothing else but the
relationship of the main god of god of
zeus with uh a woman so
but don't think one thing do not think i
know the greeks are very pragmatic
people
um and i think they are most of the most
pragmatic people in the world
even that time i can so see it in front
of me ancient greeks
i can so imagine that they were actually
making fun of the gods
they knew that they were invented they
knew that they had something to worship
and because they didn't because they
needed to worship something they
invented some stories and gods and made
them statues and everything but believe
you me
they did not believe in them they did
not believe in them in a religious way
okay for them it was some stories they
made up myths
okay they made them up in order to have
something to talk about in order to have
something to explain certain things in
order to
have something to worship in order to be
able to go to temples
in order to do all these things that
they were doing they were not
they never were religious people in such
a sense even the greeks nowadays for
example you can tell
these are not religious people they're
just traditional people it's different
being traditional being religious two
different things okay
now being religious means you believe in
god you believe in what god tells you to
do
but traditional has to do with you being
greek okay
so it's more important being greek than
being religious okay so they go back to
whatever is greek that's the important
thing okay so
speaking the greek language is more
important than any other language for
example
there is also the superiority feeling of
course of them really believing that
somebody
something something better than other
people simply because of high
civilization because of history
because of so many things that they
think they had
so all these things all this that makes
you makes you arrogant as a people
okay but again for the same reason many
other people can say the same things
they can also say
hey we also had a high civilization i
mean there is no people on this planet i
think we mentioned in the last episode
there is nobody on this planet that
didn't have a high
zenith a high point where their
civilization and culture reached
there was no people we mentioned i think
our brothers in in and sisters
in myanmar in burma you know the the
rohingya muslims
who are now refugees they once had an
empire in southeast asia
these people had once an empire in
southeast asia now they don't even have
houses to live
you see and again people who are up
there on top
they have to learn from history and this
is a very important part to learn from
don't think that you will always be up
there whoever thinks they are up there
now
they will not be forever out there they
will once fall as anybody else felt
before
that's the that's that's the sunnah of
humanity
you know humankind they're once up and
they will fall down that's for sure
that's hundred percent that's the way it
is
so subhanallah we're coming back to that
point again but as angel said indeed
you have to come back to one point you
have to come back to one god in the end
you have to come back to this one god
and it was there the whole time
and it makes sense what you said my bad
bro but um
they're just trying to fill the void
like they have this itch they have this
thing that's like
they want to worship something everyone
has it because i mean
obviously we are creations we are not
the creator
so we have this this need this want to
worship and they tried to fill that hole
with uh these
you know fake gods and these stories and
all that stuff but like you said it was
just something to
try to distract them and try to fill
this hole
it's kind of like someone having sexual
urges
whereas obviously guys you know a lot of
purposes
okay it's good it's all good and fine at
that point
but um we have these urges for a reason
their biological urges like imagine you
trying to disregard
the fact that your body wants to
actually
uh reproduce and then you're trying to
make up some
crazy thing and then have that be like
your
your void that's going to fill your void
it'd be good
to imagine it brothers i don't have to
imagine it
i see what happens in the catholic
church when these urges are not
you know when you cannot fulfill your
urges
look at the catholic church right so
you know because it's unnatural because
their religion is unnatural and the
religion is a man-made religion
you can tell it is a man-made religion
if you have these kind of issues
how can a man not get married
how can a man not fulfill his sexual
desires
how is this possible honestly any man
would say that's that's crazy that's
crazy
it is crazy and it makes it can make a
serial kill out of it
so now you wonder that the catholic
church has serious issues
of course they do the celibate issue
that they have
in the say in the catholic church
meaning that a priest cannot marry
or they cannot have sexual relationships
or whatever else
that is an issue that is a serious issue
and i remember how when i became muslim
when i became muslim at the very
beginning i remember my mother
the my parents invited the bishop
imagine that i know the bishop of
germany and austria the greek orthodox
bishop
and they invited him over because he
actually when he was a priest before he
became a bishop
he used to be my teacher my religious
teacher in at school
in primary school so i knew him he knew
me and my mother knew him also because
we came nearly from my mother comes from
the same place where he comes from
greece so she invited him over to come
to speak to him
to me to maybe you know
kind of you know take me away from the
wrong path that i was on
and he explained and actually i asked
him i said
i have just one question for you
as a greek orthodox bishop you are not
allowed to be married
whereas the greek orthodox priest can't
marry by the way but as a bishop you
cannot
so i asked him i said honestly with all
due respect
what do you do as a man
i told him and i asked him next to this
one i said
you don't have to answer me the question
what do you do with a man that's a man
but answer me the question how can a man
be a man without fulfilling the sexual
desires
god created you that way now you are
torturing yourself on a daily basis for
what
for fame for money for what
you want to tell me that you believe the
belief you believe in
so do you see that my belief is better
than yours
i was 18 19 20 by the way so i spoke
like that don't
you know i don't think i would do it
that way nowadays but still
still the truth is what do you do as a
man what do you do with the sexual
desires and why did allah create you
that way and
how come that if you are created that
way you cannot fulfill sexual desires
with simply getting married
and i'm not talking about other things
but you have to in the end you end up
doing things that
are illegal in many ways maybe
theologically maybe religiously
maybe even according to the law of a
country for example you might do things
that are crazy
because you cannot fulfill your man
manly hood you cannot be a man
and like right now right now i'm not
married
and i have a feeling that a lot of those
who are married in the muslim you know
they are
striving to uh you know stay celebrated
until they're married
but like we haven't end you know what i
mean where it's like we're doing this
for x amount of time until
we get married but if you if you were to
tell me right now hey brother uh
you have to be celibate for the rest of
your life like bro
god forgive me i'm gonna act up
i'm gonna be out of pocket doing
something of course
i'm wondering what did the bishop say
sorry
what did that business say when you
asked him that yeah
he said my dear first of all
he addressed me at the very beginning
and then he addressed my parents
and listened to what he said to me to me
he said
i chose to do what my ancestors chose
to do how i found it how i i just
followed my tradition
to my parents he turned around and said
listen he said
to them i think it's about time for me
to leave
but i want to tell you one thing i am
very happy
having met a young man who is looking
trying to find god
so let him be let him be as he is that's
exactly what he said to my parents
they never had any contacts at that time
again my parents didn't expect this from
him
and he got up he really showed a lot of
respect until the day of today you know
what he told me and i know where he is
and you know i'm every time i'm saying
whenever i'm in germany i want to go and
visit him he's in berlin
um until the day of today there's a lot
of respect
not for me as a muslim but for me as
somebody
who is looking for god and for him i'm
wrong obviously you know
i think i believe uh i must be wrong i
mean he's a bishop so i must be wrong in
his eyes but i'm somebody i'm a
youngster who normally youngsters are
interested in going out having parties
having fun you know all this stuff
that's the idea right and
he appreciated that someone my age
is looking into something different he's
looking into
the meaning of life into god and he had
it very seldom he did not know that from
others
so that's what he said to my parents and
that shocked my parents so much that
they have no contact with them anymore
it's insane that's the same man
uh at least he was real about it you
know and yeah he's cool
he was cool actually i must really say
that i did like him even during that
time of my school time
i was not very religious but um i did
have a lot of respect for him
um and i think that
he's quite real and if i ever have the
chance and i hope i'll like give you the
chance once
to go and visit him really and and like
like the two of us just have a personal
private conversation now
now 30 years later plus i would like to
talk to him in private
and i would like to actually make him
explain
to me why he has taken the path he has
and he will consider if he's interested
in god rather
than in that what he has now and i would
just tell him very simple things i would
make him understand very
very simple i would speak to him in a
very simple way okay
i would not insult him i would not
insult his religion but i would make
clear and sure that he has to understand
that
um what he's doing there he didn't have
to do that all his life
and it must be quite depressing to see
that you don't have to do what you're
doing what you're going through
um you could have had a much better life
it must be depressing i'm sorry you know
oh yeah for sure
i got onto this thing um a while back
because
you know i had a i had a big big problem
with pornography and i'm not afraid to
say no alhamdulillah
i'm past that but i found this thing
called
nofap and nofap is basically this
movement where
people stop watching pornography they
stop um
you know pleasing themselves and doing
this hedonistic stuff to
be able to overcome that uh addiction
right and then from there
i learned about this thing known as
semen retention
which is a form of celibacy and it it
stems a lot from
uh i want to say the hindus
um i think it's called a brahma
brahmachara or something like that
i don't know anyways the whole practice
of sema retention is like
you retain your seed which supposedly
has like this power
and you your mental thought process
becomes better
you won't have more energy and all that
stuff and and
i did it for so long that i was like man
this is depressing
like i need to be with a girl i need to
fulfill my urges i need to do
something and i tried telling people i'm
like yo
like this isn't it guys like this is
cool in short periods of time but like
you're not a monk you're not trying to
um you're not a priest you're not trying
to live this lifestyle where you're
never going to be with a woman again
yeah like you don't want that so why are
you trying to live that way
because of these benefits that people
are talking about
but it's it's crazy man it goes to show
you
you can't feel a void you can't feel a
hole with something that's not meant to
go in
survival i mean um yes i cannot imagine
myself brother i mean
honestly a man is made to be a man in
many ways a man does of course
it's not sexuality only that divine's a
man however it is a very important part
of a man
why is it in in islamic marriage for
example
and we ended up i mean from history we
ended up talking about uh
about about our sex life and everything
which is a very important topic by the
way i think
it has become a taboo topic by the way
for muslims nowadays which i don't
understand
why it is like this because we do have
in the past by the way
history again we do have books written
um
like the kama sutra for example you know
you're talking about hindu hinduism
like the kama sutra you know there is an
equivalent book written by muslims
which is halal okay so written by
muslims
about your sex love and what you can do
what you cannot do what you should avoid
and so on and so on
masha'allah i mean why is it now this
topic
why why are we muslims nowadays
you know but i think it's again us
western muslims who will change that
perception because um we combine again
the um the real islam the real openness
of islam
because islam is quite an open open deen
um
and to to to the western-minded
um um tolerance and everything you know
that is islam subhanallah whereas if you
look at
some of our older muslims coming from
muslim countries they have learned to
really
to to to make things taboo and not to
discuss them
right which is not islamic which is not
islamic
rasulullah you know we know we know how
a sex life is supposed to be
if we just know what rasulullah we know
every moment of his life
we know how his sex life was we know
what we're allowed to do and we're not
allowed to do
how can this be taboo if rasulullah was
and his wives right so how can this be
taboo
how come we make a taboo but yeah to go
back to that actually what you were
saying
absolutely we we should how can you as a
muslim
have a fulfilled life as a man first of
all as a man
be fulfilled in your life if you don't
have a fulfilled like sex life
it's a problem and islam
gives you the solution again we don't
have priests and imams and bishops
and all this stuff you know and imam is
anybody who who prays in front of
someone i was imam today
for my family you know my son can be
imam you know this whole issue of
the muslim community nowadays making out
of imams priests
that i find honestly disgusting
appalling
because now we're coming closer to the
idea of where i ran away from i ran away
from this
idea of clergy and people who know
everything
they they can be found in churches you
know and then you ask
if you want a solution to your problem
if you want to find god you go to the
priest
now if you want to find god you've got
to be ima
right what is that what imam who what we
don't have priests
we don't know these things we run away
from these things and you see the
muslims going through that subhanallah
subhanallah it's a catastrophe
honestly you know in certain countries
more than in others
but if you take turkey as an example for
example they are a clear copy
of uh the greek orthodox system they
have imams and they have people
you go to if you have a problem in
turkey you go to the imam
you go you have a problem in greece you
go to the priest exactly the same thing
then you go and the imam gives you
certain things that you have to say and
do
you go to the greek orthodox priest he
does the same it's like wow
what is the difference between orthodox
christianity in greece
and islam in turkey i dare saying nearly
none
that's how bad it has become you know
and that's just an example that i gave
you of two peoples who went out quite
well
and there are others who will find the
same you can find the same catastrophe
you will find the same problems okay we
have moved
really we have gone we have gone so far
away from islam from our roots
from our islamic roots that indeed we
have to be taken back
and history is one of the most important
uh becomes one of the most important
topic in order for us to go back again
to understand
what actually islam means and not what
our
grandparents do now what our parents do
now no no we have to go further
to understand what islam actually means
yeah that reminds me of
when i was when i was christian
and i would go to the church i was with
my
fiance at the time and we would go to
these um these
bible groups right and then uh you would
have the the pastor in the group
with a whole bunch of people and we
would read uh parts of the scripture and
then we would say like what we think the
scripture means
and then the the priest the pastor would
actually say what it really means
so it's like okay you guys can say what
you think it means but look i'm gonna
just tell you exactly what it means
and like to me i like i literally said
it right that i was like i don't get it
how you can tell me exactly the
interpretation of this
when all of us are receiving different
interpretations and
what's what's beautiful subhanallah in
the quran
it um man i wish i could pull it up
because i have it on my phone
but uh there's a specific verse where
it says um i'm gonna butcher it
but it's uh to not interpret uh
man i gotta i gotta look it up give me a
sec give me a second you mean are you
talking about
the uh that they make them as their gods
that uh the priests are made as their
gods are you talking about that specific
ayah
no no i'm gonna find it right now give
me one second okay
that's cool in the meanwhile yes in the
meanwhile
maybe you want to say something brothers
you didn't say that
i had a really it might be a personal
question so
no hard feelings if you don't want to
answer it but how did your family
your parents take it when you reverted
and
what is the state of your relationship
with them
to today okay um
very very important question um look
because of my background you know as i
said i'm greek maurice of origin
my parents are not very religious never
were religious as i said the greek
people are very pragmatic they're not
religious and they're very traditional
so when they saw when i became 14 15 and
i was interested in religion and i got a
muslim friend that time and
i started reading about islam and other
type of religions they just saw it as a
face
and they just let me do that was a good
thing
but when they started seeing that i
became more serious in islam and i
traveled also to find out
um about islam and i went to the mosque
and i started learning surname
it became a little bit of problem so
then
suddenly it was they took me aside my
mother took me aside i said do you have
any problems
okay do you have any problems that was
the question
i said mom i to be very honest um
i do have some but i don't i don't know
exactly what you mean
uh so she was like do you have any you
know identity issue you grew up in
germany might this be a problem you're
trying to find an identity
you're greek i mean you go off into
greece no problem i said no no
absolutely that that is the least of my
problem i said i know who i
am you know uh if you meant this
absolutely not but if you refer to islam
i said well look listen
listen i am talking about god you know
i'm talking about finding some kind of
a national identity or whatever i'm
talking about god i'm talking about
your creator my creator so that freaked
them even more out
so when i was thinking like this it
didn't make sense at all
so sadly i became religious i was not
religious at all you know as i said
so suddenly these things you know it's
like something is going on you see maybe
maybe he learns too much
maybe uh he needs to you know make a
step back from books
maybe reads too much and then they saw
that it was a little bit
more serious than they thought so they
started what i mentioned before
they got me the bishop to speak to they
got me to speak to priests before the
bishop came
then i officially declared that i become
muslim that took me three years by the
way because i knew these issues
and i knew the problems and um
what happened more is that it it became
very aggressive
okay and i had to leave my parents place
so i had to leave my parents place i was
actually basically thrown out on the
street
let's let's call it as it is so i went
to stay at a brother's place for a while
and would have contact with my parents
on bases
on basis of the advice that i was given
by brothers do not cut off the ties with
your family
and i couldn't understand it that time
and i couldn't understand i couldn't see
it i was actually upset and angry with
them i said what are you talking about
my father hit me my mother is upset with
me what are you saying there how can i
be in contact with these people as a
i know they're my parents but you know
at this moment
no i don't want to have any contact with
them and alhamdulillah
and again for anybody who listens to us
that's one of the best advice
i keep giving to youngsters with these
kind of issues
keep in touch with your parents because
look when i became muslim
years later and the relationship became
better with my
parents my mother said one's at the
table listen
although we hit you although we kicked
you out of your parents place
although we were terrible and violent
towards you you kept coming back to us
and calling us
if this is islam then it's good these
were the first and last words that my
mother said
about islam that makes me still so
emotional if i think of that
okay and this is somebody who hates
islam
okay this is somebody who's islam so
again a tip and advice and a hint for
everyone
it is a very difficult situation that
time i didn't understand that i didn't
understand why i had to do it i did it
because i was told to and i thought oh
my god sometimes i would just call say
something and hang out
okay so it was very difficult but
the best advice was this advice and i'm
happy that i followed this advice
and i can give this through to my next
to the next generation to my
children and to others as well so yes
follow islam if you follow islam
everything will be right in china indeed
it's not just an empty slogan it is like
this it really is like this
allah will test you for a while after a
while the test is over
okay inshallah after a while it's over
as difficult as it might seem to be
it was very difficult i tell you but i
cannot go too deep into everything but
it was very difficult
and it was so difficult as i said i had
to leave my parents place i
just spoke to them on the phone i hadn't
seen them for a long long period of time
um until things calmed down a bit and
every time
i would go back to my parents place
there was an argument every time
every time every time there was
something
and if you're asking me about how it is
today look 30 years down the line i have
my older son is 22 years old
okay and until the day of today they do
not accept that these children are
muslims
they tell me listen you can be what you
want to that's your problem i don't care
anymore
but we do care about our grandchildren
they can decide as they decided
as you decided for yourself let them
decide i said yeah that's exactly what
i'm doing
but i give them something to decide they
have an and a b to decide
but you just gave me a and i decided
i found myself a b and if i don't give
them
a and b to decide how can they decide
between a and b
if i just gave them a meaning what the
world gives them
i you're right i give them the choice
but i give them the choice between a
and b right but you don't want a and b
you want just a you want one specific
thing
because actually what you want is for
them to go astray
because you are saying as you found your
way let them also find their way
why why do they have to go through so
much trouble i don't understand
why shouldn't they have it easier in a
way of i give them
a and i give them b the world is out
there that's a
i give them b so let them decide they
still decide to make up their minds
no problem why do they have to go
through trouble
travel drugs women this that why do you
have to do that
why let them live their life what do you
mean with that
it's another slogan again right the like
saying that live your life
live your life what they mean with that
go out have fun drugs
disco you know do what you do and then
come back
but who says that you will be able to
come back don't we know how many cases
do we know out there
who have never come back anymore
honestly brothers that's the truth how
many cases do we know that people have
not come back anymore
that have died on od how many cases do
we know
with hiv what do you do yeah enjoy your
life right and according to them is like
have as many as many women as you want
to
and then you come back a wedge i mean
what then what then what have i done
you know what i'm saying you know just
because you don't want islam
look what they're telling you they would
prefer even
if i had said i don't want to get
married ever
i want to have fun they would have
preferred this one to what i know
to being a muslim to being a man to
being a
family father to having seven children
to having a stable life a stable income
all this stuff they would have preferred
me
rather being um
anything yes anything but being what i
am
[Music]
my mother even went so far to say she
would rather
really believe it or not she would
rather have my sister being
a prostitute than being a muslim
that's terrible what do you say on
something like
see when i was young and if you told me
that i would be like nah you know that's
maybe it's an exception
maybe your mom's just like that listen
i'm 23 and i'm i'm nowhere near as
you know experienced as some of the
older generations
in terms of life but what i've seen in
these last couple of years
for islamophobia and the hatred and
other non-muslim families
crazy man it's absurd and it stems from
just
just this prejudice there's no bias no
maybe even subconsciously they realize
maybe this is something but
it's just an ego it scares them even
i never forget you know conversations
i've had with with relatives and
everything religious people even
it scares them when they realize that
there is something in there it scares
them they get up they want to leave they
don't want to talk anymore
it scares them so much that it might be
that you are right and if you're right
somebody even told me
it might be that you're right but you
know what i don't care i'm greek and i'm
going to die
so what you're talking about i'm greek
too i'm going to die greek too you still
you haven't understood what i was just
saying
you know we were having a conversation
of two hours and in the end you come and
give me such a nonsense
that is nonsense what you just said i'm
greek to it i'm gonna die great too
so now what do you want to say about
that what they want to say i know what
they want to say obviously
you know that's what i found it's
exactly what the quraysh said
exactly subhanallah we think now 1400
years down the lane we think now
that actually you know the problems are
different nowadays the world has changed
nothing has changed everything is the
same
everything has remained the same the
problems are exactly the same
the utterings are exactly the same my
grandparents did it so i do that too
i do what my parents do i don't know
anything else i don't know any better
that's exactly what the quraish said
that's how we do it in pakistan that's
how i do it too i don't care if it's
right or wrong
that's it right you know that we all
know that we know this kind of
expression let's examine
what our people say you know my my mom
does this i do that too
if i did what my parents did i would be
an alcoholic nowadays yeah
so i mean come on what kind of what are
these utterings it's
appalling it's terrible it's dangerous
it's dangerous this kind of other things
are dangerous
it's crazy man that's crazy and to touch
on what you said about the um
the thing where some some people go out
there and they live life
but they never come back like man that
that's so true
yeah and man like when i was when i was
jai when i was in my jahilia
um i in
but what's that word you use that starts
with the p
buy it promiscuous i wasn't promiscuous
i didn't have multiple partners
not that i didn't want to but just
because i didn't want to have
sexually transmitted diseases i didn't
want to have aids i didn't want to have
hiv i didn't want
any of that stuff and it's crazy because
like my entire family
um anytime i would visit they would
always ask me like oh how many
girlfriends do you have now
yes i got one
yeah yeah i know what you mean a very
great thing
do they say these things too really i
know that the greeks are like a typical
thing when you're a young boy you're
like 12
13 so how many girlfriends do you have
that's a typical question
yeah okay it's a little bit embarrassing
to be very honest that you have to
answer
in front of your ankles and arms that
you actually don't have
or that you just have one or whatever
you know so yeah they kind of like look
down on you they're like
oh like only one or like you don't have
any yeah
what's wrong with you is it are you gay
or something is that a problem yeah
yeah yeah for real that's exactly right
yeah but guys what i had earlier
i'm gonna read it right it was chapter
it was chapter three verse seven bro i
remember what you wrote
yeah so um it says in the quran
says here it is who has sent down to you
the book
in which our verses definitive and clear
and meaning
they are the foundation of the book and
others which are allegor
allegorical but those in whose hearts is
perversity they follow the allegorical
part
so as to create dissensions seeking to
interpret it even though none know its
interpretation
except allah and um then it says and
those who are from the rooted knowledge
say we believe in it
it is all for my lord but only men of
understanding pay
heed yeah and when i had when i had read
that part in the quran like it brought
me back
to the time when i was in that in that
bible study
and the pastor was trying to tell us
exactly
what this specific passage meant when
everyone else had a different
interpretation
wow it's kind of like you know and allah
is right because when you hear
non-muslims or islamophobes
they'll pull out a verse from chapter
nine and be like what is this
and they'll just cherry pick verses but
they won't understand about the context
the sequential order of revelation not
just the order of the quran and
you know just stuff like that they won't
get it yeah the reason i say that is
because
like that's how it should be like islam
is the template it's the instruction
manual
like here this is it but like it's it's
the dean
and like me me fighting gabriel
that's how you say his last name we were
talking about this and it's like
you know the dean is going to be
different
you know slightly different for each
person now obviously we all follow the
same template
but we're not all going to follow it 100
to a t the same exact way
you know we can only hope that we do
but you know inshallah we do we don't
know we probably won't
and like what you're saying that like
there shouldn't be
the mom you don't go to the mom and
you're like hey
uh what does this mean how do i do this
over here like you don't
seek for the answers from this person
because that person
i hate to say is imperfect and we all
know
what the only perfect thing is and
that's
allah so
yeah that's why i said what i said yeah
that's what i love
when you go to like you know you look at
fatwas and like rulings
you'll see it says you know majority of
scholars unanimously agree this
there's no you know you can't say allah
said this because that's a re that's
there's a lot of strength behind that
now there's a lot of repercussions you
talking about allah's religion what if
you're unsure so you know
you people most usually say majority of
scholars say this or most scholars agree
with this
and then some scholars say it's this
because
you know they have to go through their
studies and come up with their own
understanding of fail
now there's things that are set in stone
in the quran um but the things that are
not
that's where it's like most scholars
agree with this type thing you know like
but i appreciate that it's not like
you know this preset so so it's
literally like a ruling exactly
exactly it's like none of them are
coming out saying look this is exactly
what it means and this is how you have
to follow and this is what you have to
do it's like no
um we're all kind of agreeing that this
is
probably what the interpretation
is now you do you but we're just
all coming as a collective here and
saying like we know we we kind of agree
this is it
but you do you you know it's is your
life your decision
i like reading between the lines of
connecting the dots because
you know how you said in it are verses
that are clear and then there are other
ones that are allegorical or not really
so black and white and then the you know
the disbelievers use these to
you know sway us and talk about i like
that because for me
i extract the integrity or the moral
universe
of islam from the clear verses so when
it comes to the things that are unclear
i use my understanding
and morality and sense of integrity that
i got from the
on from the clear verses you know what i
mean
like for example like it doesn't talk
about
let's say um music
just give me an example i know music to
be haram from you know everything else i
stopped listening to music but
you don't see that in the quran in the
quran you do
it does talk about you know addictions
and intoxicants and stuff like that
then when you learn a bit about music
you learn okay it could lead that way
so for me that's why i stopped listening
to music you know but somebody else
might look at it another way
but you need to look at the clear verses
and extract from there um
yeah i think that's important
yeah michelle absolutely i mean um the
the the thing is it's fascinating to see
a book
one book like the quran is one book
and every time you read the quran you
feel that you have
never come across certain passages
although you have read it so many times
like hey
how come it's true in it it's like it's
like
how come i've had i thought i knew and
a certain surah you're like i thought i
knew that surah but where was that
before
i forgot about it i never paid attention
to that specific one because it fit to
my life at this moment
and i
with the courses that i'm doing now for
example the
uh islamic history in europe in the
world actually how islam spread in the
world
i'm trying now to um the first
the first one that i started islam in
europe um
i took i saw a lot of things that
i wouldn't have thought that i would be
able to find in the quran
or in hadith that actually
tell you um how to interpret historical
events
um give an example imagine now
in europe in the 13th 14th century
there were once people who were called
tatars they still exist tatar people
still exist they live in tatarstan in
bashkordustan
in russia in the ukraine in the crimea
peninsula and so on
so you do have tatar people what
happened to them they fled from the
mongols
and they found refuge in that time
europe
lithuania and poland which was one
empire at that time
so they entered that lithuanian toilet
of polish lithuanian empire
it was a christian empire and they were
allowed to stay there
they were even allowed to marry
christian women
which that time and we were talking
about the 13th 14th century europe
that was unbelievable that a muslim
could come and marry
your women that that was not never the
case nowhere else
but there was a case there they allowed
them to stay they gave them
even villages to live in they gave them
the possibility to
have madrasas
and the people their children whom they
got with women who were
christian women they were educated in
quran and in arabic and that was masha
allah so
it seems like honey flowers and beasts
right everything is wonderful and great
but what happened to these people in the
end they
assimilated so much that nowadays we
don't have tatars anymore we have nearly
no muslims in poland in lithuania
in the ukraine and the crimean peninsula
you know we have a tiny minority of
people here and there
some here some there some tatars who
call themselves starters don't know the
data language don't even know arabic
don't know how to pray
don't go to the masjid many don't
consider themselves being muslim
what is what happened they have
assimilated totally
into that society okay and
when you understand i mean i take the
the the
my understanding from there is put it on
to present we are living nowadays in the
west
all of us we as muslims might as a
minority minority community
we live in the west might be north
america might be south america might be
europe wherever we live
and we have to now adjust
like the tatas had to adjust some of us
even marry christian women non-muslim
women
but we have to now be careful how we
gonna keep up our islam in life
how we gonna educate our next generation
children in islam
now even if the woman is a christian
which you you're allowed to marry fine
however your children have to be
educated in islam
they have to be muslims muslim children
and they have to actually get
their quranic understanding the islamic
understanding they have to be muslims
okay now there is an extremely difficult
extremely big challenge
and i can see now how easily you can
drift into assimilation rather than into
integration
these are two totally different ways
okay and
and politicians in the west and and and
even muslims in the west
do not even distinguish between the one
and the other although they are two
fundamentally different things
integrate is something that allah is
telling us to do
we are supposed to integrate in a
society
but it is haram to assimilate
because when we assimilate we become
that the majority non-muslim society
we become non-muslims we become kuffar
and our children more so actually are
not even muslims anymore
so we assimilation is haram whereas
integration
is wished for that's what we need to do
the problem now is as we've discovered
now in certain courses for example
we're talking a lot about what does it
actually mean integration how far does
integration go
okay we need as muslims living in the
west we all need
to create a kind of program plan
idea definition of the word integration
versus assimilation to tell the majority
non-muslims
listen guys we muslims we want
to be able to speak your language we
want to go to your schools
we want to have this kind of context and
whatever
but we don't want our women to be taken
off the hijabs we don't want our women
to feel persecuted at work
we don't want to have no to not have
a break to pray whereas others can go
every two hours and have a smoky
small break you know you know they can
these things
so we don't want that and that's what we
want this way we don't want
and this is something i miss we don't
have this we don't have anybody to come
out we don't have our
we're not strong enough although we have
millions millions of people in the west
we we should come out finally and say
listen
you make the politic the political
program for us but we want to make it
for you
we want to make this program for us you
know we
give you the program that that you want
to make for us we want to tell you
actually how we want to do it
and because it is disastrous if you look
at france for example
you must have heard what what's
happening in france you know
in switzerland first it was no nicap
then it was
no minaret now soon it's going to be no
hijab after no he just
so where are we going to and what are we
doing in the meanwhile
okay and we need to again that's why
history comes in there
and that's what we need to know our
history in order to understand that the
next
step after that is actually 1933.
that's the next step
okay and europe became a judeo-christian
continent
simply because of the holocaust before
the holocaust
it was only a christian continent and
nobody would have ever mentioned the
jews
for the christians in europe before the
holocaust
the jews were actually just a minority
as we are nowadays as muslims in europe
but after the holocaust it became a
judeo-christian
civilization in europe what is happening
here now
what is going on what has to happen for
them to understand
that actually islam was as much in the
picture as judaism was
even more so in europe islam was part of
europe
in the 8th century not in 1960 as they
make us believe
that people came to work in the
factories that's not true
that is much much longer it goes back
okay and this is what i mentioned last
time in the book that i have here the
islamic history of europe by the way
whoever wants to know more about it
detailed about what happened in europe
and it is important also for people in
north america
by the way i've also written some books
you can find on my website with regards
to islam in the americas
north and south america and islam in
africa for example that's something i
wanted to
mention as well so but we need to
understand that these things happen in
the past
and what the result was of these things
in the past in order for
to have us to avoid this result nowadays
subhanallah you know so i just wanted to
say that
i think we're coming close at close to
an end actually
and um we need to understand that
there's so much we can discuss
panel i didn't even realize look how
long we've been talking i didn't realize
that time just
just just passed you know like last time
episode one
i just subhanallah i just don't know
anyone there's so much
if i start something else again it's
gonna go another hard so
i give the world to you i've never been
to a lecture in university
and kept my attention for longer than
like
five to ten minutes yeah you've been
talking for like an hour and a half
and i could listen all day i'm just
super present and
everything you're saying is real it's
not fairy tale it's not
folklore or mythology like we talked
about it's all real and it's personable
i can relate to it
indeed i think one thing that i've heard
from my students as well
um but i'm trying
to be as as as neutral as as unbiased as
i can be
of course anybody any person on this
planet um
has a certain opinion we all are in a
way biased
but in order to be a professional now
in our beings and also in order to be a
not only a professional historian but
also
a muslim we have to be unbiased and
neutral towards everything else
um because otherwise it's as if we say
islam is wrong
so we have to try to make it right to
make it fitting make islam fit in there
no
we don't have to make islam fit because
islam fits
when you tell the truth islam fits you
don't have to make islam
you know and this is what i realized
with a lot of muslim
brothers who are trying to make islam
fit
into their lifestyle which is a
non-islamic lifestyle and they come and
tell you listen i'm a good muslim as
well or i'm trying to be
whatever you know you don't need to come
and tell me or you know you don't need
to
convince me about that that is between
you and europe
you know you are there you're standing
there you know you are praying towards
him hopefully and if you don't then
what can i say so um
you see try to be as authentic as
possible as a human being with telling
the truth
and i think that's what i keep hearing
from a lot of my students also that
they respect and admire me in the way
that i'm just telling the truth without
having to hide behind behind my hands or
fingers
you know there's a saying in greek that
you're right you hide behind your
fingers
you know basically you don't tell the
truth you don't you're just trying to
make it fit
no no no no if something is wrong then
something is wrong i'm gonna say that
and if something
is wrong in islamic history then i'm
gonna say it is wrong
it happened but it was wrong okay i'm
not gonna
honey coat it sugar coat it and make it
seem as if it was something
you know which is great part of islam no
it was things of that in the islamic
history a lot of things happen
that we cannot be proud of i tell you
that you know we all have an impression
we all believe
that islamic history is full of angels
walking on the streets a hobby
you know that all the dynasties were
perfect and we all did the right thing
and all our emperors were
amazing absolutely wrong it created
wrong it couldn't be wronger than that
you know we have had some terrible
people in you
we have had some terrible rulers worse
than some some non-muslim rulers
we have had some disastrous situations
among the muslims
we have to say these things that's how
it is otherwise we will never understand
what
really happened i think this is my
my end these are my envoys basically my
last one
all right i know thoughts well at the
end of the day it always goes back to
history
the beautiful way to end it yeah i think
saying
any more would just make it less so
let's wrap it up
a lot of people have this misconception
that you know once i feel closer to god
then i'm going to start practicing
it's backwards you won't feel close to
god until you start practicing the
prophet i said
there's a hadith where he says that the
most beloved acts of worship to god are
those which he made obligatory the
person continues to get closer and
closer to allah
key point gets closer and closer by
voluntary acts of good so like sudden
things you know for the sake of allah
things that are not obligatory but you
do them just to please allah
until allah begins to love the person so
two things you want to feel close to
allah you want allah to love you
do what allah uh prescribes for you
which is
so praying fasting and shadow allah
and then on top of that sunnah prayers
suddenly fasts
giving extra charity to the point where
allah will insha allah begin to love you
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]